the man's bedroom hadn't been silent for
over 100 years now the carpet had been
worn down a thick layer of dust had
gathered on every surface and the same
trapped air had stagnated for so long
that had become unbearable for anyone
entering the room but no one was allowed
to enter the room nobody could open that
door ever again or it could Mark the
beginning of not just an apocalypse but
a breakdown in the nature of reality
itself figures shuffled around the room
sometimes dozens sometimes as few as
three all rotting but never dying
researchers peered through the window in
abject Terror day after day as the laws
of physics broke down before their very
eyes all of them except one a lone
scientist with a plan to get inside that
room a plan that the foundation would
shoot him dead for a plan that he was
seconds away from enacting as they
improvised explosive device in this
Satchel clunked heavily against his
thigh in many ways we are just as
trapped as scp-001 if not more so we are
trapped in our own three-dimensional
world take a stick figure drawn on a
piece of paper that stick figure knows
up and down left and right that is their
world you draw a box around them and
they are trapped unable to Simply step
forward out of the page and walk around
it for us looking down at the stick
figure we might laugh at their
foolishness trapped inside a child's
drawing of a house it begs the question
is there a creature looking down at us
and laughing we may be able to move up
and down left and right forward and
backward outsmarting the simple stick
figure but in time we are just as caged
in living our entire lives on this
razor-thin piece of paper called the
present the future is always just Out Of
Reach the past always repelling us we
have no choice but to exist in the now
slowly creeping through history without
any agency of our own cursed to be born
Live and Die in that order you can never
be a child again never see your mother's
face for the first time beaming down at
you you cannot skip ahead to your dying
minutes knowing what it is you will have
to face up to in your life maybe the
idea of facing up to things at all will
fade with the freedom of exploring what
once was and what will be as if it were
no more difficult than taking a step out
of a 2d box the bell rang cutting
Professor Davies off he hadn't meant to
go into such an existential tangent
especially for his first year students
most of them look like they were in a
daze not really listening to anything he
had been saying quantum mechanics sure
was a complex topic to cover in just one
semester at University he'd spent his
entire career trying to wrap his head
around it and still spend most of his
days with the same bored and Confused
glaze over his eyes as the teenagers who
made their way to the back of the hall
but one figure standing just beyond the
doorway peering down at him caught the
professor's eye little did he know how
drastically his career was about to
change in just a few minutes a
preeminent physicist at just 28 years
old Professor Davies had already
achieved the status that many academics
will not see within their lifetimes
whenever anyone asked him about it he
always made the joke that he was
cheating he didn't believe in the
concept of a linear lifetime in the
first place still too young to be taken
seriously by many of his peers he had
flown under the academic radar for much
of his career so far perhaps it was as
simple as that or perhaps certain
undercover agents had a hand in
suppressing news of his blossoming
career in Quantum research his hands
trembled as he approached the reinforced
glass he gripped the bag tightly trying
his best not to let his fear show if any
of them saw what he was about to do they
even suspected something he would have a
dozen bullets flying through the back of
his skull before he'd even have a chance
to put his hands up shifting his weight
from foot to foot he waited for the
airlock to be open for him a siren
blared red lights flashed and the first
glass doors slid open stepping inside he
waited for the atmosphere in the chamber
to adjust both doors were closed in
front of and behind him if they wanted
to kill him now would be the time he
closed his eyes and waited with baited
breath the bomb weighing heavily on his
shoulder but they would not kill him he
knew that now what he was about to do
was inevitable it took several months
for Professor Davies to be granted the
full security clearance he needed they
kept referring to his project as a
k-class anomaly whatever that meant in
order to get him up to speed with the
nature of what he was going to be
working on the foundation assigned him
to various other scps first
scp-5027 2821 1887 any instance that had
some link to Quantum Mechanics or
complex theoretical physics they
wouldn't even tell him which SCP he was
being trained up to work on until one
morning when a team of Agents was
waiting for him at the door to his
quarters he wasn't allowed to bring a
bag or any personal possessions standard
issue clothing a toothbrush and
everything else he needed would all be
provided for him it was only then that
they told him which SCP he was being
assigned to
scp-001 he was blindfolded for the
entirety of the journey Carr then plane
then another car it was a full 10 hours
before his blindfold was removed and his
new project was revealed to him
professor Davies found himself in
sight01 the place where all of this
started all the scps all the research
the secrecy the assassinations the
deaths of countless innocent people and
an equal number of guilty parties it all
started right here SCI zero one the side
itself resembled a large sarcophagus
similar to the one found covering the
Chernobyl nuclear power plant where do
you think the Soviets got the blueprints
from everything in the room is arranged
in a circle around the center research
desks maintenance equipment raw
materials including a stockpile of
wooden planks and reinforced Metal
Sheets monitoring equipment security
cameras and of course some of the most
advanced automatic weapon systems in the
world all pointed at a great glass box
in the middle of the hangar measuring 30
meters in each Direction the glass was
50 centimeters thick even all those High
Caliber weapons would have had a hard
time creating a chip in that but it
wasn't the glass box itself that was so
interesting it was what was trapped
inside of it a house inside a perfectly
round glass bowl with no entrances or
exits complete with a front lawn
sidewalk porch and even a tree in the
backyard a regular American house
trapped in a box like some kind of
science experiment there was some kind
of transparent airlock system at the
entrance on the other side was just a
normal walk of the garden path to the
edge of the second glass bubble
enclosing the house but on closer
inspection Professor Davies realized
that this wasn't your typical American
house at all the Street Lamp wasn't
electric it was made of iron with little
glass paint Windows an oil lamp in fact
the house did look odd to him there was
no electric doorbell but instead an
actual physical Bell System the whole
house looked out of place not just
because it was in a box in the central
Hangar of a 42 000 ton sarcophagus but
because it was from another era entirely
you see site-01 was constructed around
this house the glass box and bubble
sarcophagus all of it was built around
the already existing building beneath
the foundations a hundred meters beneath
the surface is an immense metal plate
that forms a perfect deal with the
defenses up top the only way in and out
of site-01 is through an immense
reinforced door but even all those
defenses will prove utterly futile if
anyone ever opens the thin wooden door
to the bedroom on the top floor of the
house that is the home and the prison in
which scp-001 is trapped it is the job
of the foundation to make sure that it
remains trapped there indefinitely what
is
scp-001 as Professor Davies made his way
through the airlock for the very first
time and entered the site under the
supervision of four of the highest
ranking SCP staff alive today he laid
eyes on the entity itself for the first
time standing on a scissor lift parked
outside the front of the house just
inches away from the glass bubble it was
lifted high enough to look through the
window into what looked like a young
boy's bedroom on the top floor layers of
dust coated the surfaces black and white
photos sat in frames antique children's
toys sat all around the walls but Davies
didn't notice any of them he was too
busy watching the men walking in all
directions
unhurried but with purpose well over a
dozen men walked in all directions
across the carpeted floor they were all
identical around six feet with heavy
rotting skin that seemed to hang off
their limbs like it would a carcass left
in the sun human cadavers Milling about
in a young boy's bedroom Davies was so
taken aback by their appearance and
behavior that it took him a long time to
notice something truly strange the
reason he was brought here in the first
place they were walking through the bed
in the middle of the room not just over
it or around it but straight through it
as if it wasn't there but wait something
else was wrong too there weren't 12 of
them in the room it was closer to 20 had
he miscounted a moment ago then he saw
it take place one of the cadavers
reached the edge of the room and paused
as if in thought at that moment it split
not in half but rather two versions of
itself emerge from where one had been
standing both walking in different
directions a thrill of excitement ran
through Professor Davey's body the
uncertainty principle it was there in
action in front of him he was looking at
Schrodinger's cat inside the box and
seeing both its corpse and its living
self where uncertainty exists this
entity was somehow embodying both
possibilities in real time he watched
the two selves walk around the room
following different paths for several
minutes until eventually they converged
again back into one being he turned to
the researcher accompanying him lit up
with excitement and asked what they were
doing here the researcher's face was
Grim when he replied they're pacing
waiting the airlock door hissed open he
felt the stale 1800s air hitting his
face perfectly maintained at 20 degrees
in front of him was the Garden Path
leading up to his goal that glass bubble
ripping the Satchel he set off up the
path slow enough not to attract any
unwarranted attention over the next few
days Professor Davies learned everything
that the foundation had on scp-001 it
had been a human once a radical
physicist born in the late 19th century
intent on kick-starting the next Century
with a nuclear Renaissance the young man
had created a working model for stable
nuclear fusion the potential
ramifications were enormous free clean
electricity on a mass scale with no
harmful byproducts his research was
almost complete when a covert private
military group poisoned him with his own
radioactive nuclear agent the young man
made it back to his house where he died
in his sleep that night powerful
military personnel and prominent
scientists who had been working
alongside the young man knew immediately
what had happened bursting into his home
they were about to walk through his
bedroom door and save him when they saw
the shadow of two feet standing by the
door then another pair the young
scientist had died but he also hadn't
much like Schrodinger cat the man was
suspended in a dual state of death and
not death this shocking Discovery led
the group of people present to form a
rudimentary Foundation established to
secure and contain their once friend
within his room never to be discovered
by The Wider world through close
observations since this time it has been
established that scp-001 exists
independently of linear time in a kind
of superposition relative to the world
around it it is capable of occupying any
space that will or has been empty at any
point in time say you have two chairs in
a room one chair has always been there
the other was added to the room just
five minutes before the SCP is unable to
walk through the chair that was always
there since it has always existed but
the chair that was added can be passed
through with no problem because there
was a point in time when that chair had
not been there but it also works in the
future if a third chair was present
which had always been there but was
removed five minutes after the
experiment SCP
001 could pass through that chair also
the foundation theorizes and hopes that
the start of this clock that scp-001
operates on was the point at which the
young scientist died and did not die
that is why it is incapable of escaping
its bedroom and that is why it is of
vital importance that the bedroom door
remains closed forever ongoing
maintenance work and preservation
techniques are being employed to keep
the house in as stable a state as
possible should anything happen to
damage the Integrity of the structure
the quantum chaos contained in that
space could lead to a total breakdown of
the laws of physics destroying not just
the world but the fundamentals of
mathematics as we know them the bomb
bumped against Professor Davey's thighs
he walked up to the house an old man
whose life had been devoted to denying
the world its future a reality where
what is and what could be are just as
real as one another a world where the
pain of living in the now Fades when you
can travel to any moment in your life
and relive its Joy when you aren't
trapped by the aging process infinite
renewable energy to solve The World's
problems a chance to see your deceased
loved ones again a way to look at the
universe Through The Eyes Of God the
head of 001 containment he had spent his
entire career overriding all of the
safeguards tweaking containment rules
just enough each year also he could walk
across this grass with a satchel on his
shoulder and an explosive more important
than the atomic bomb at his hip he
approached the glass of the inner sphere
if he had done the math right this
should do just enough damage to create a
hole in the containment structure the
pressure change wouldn't be too great
inside but it should be just enough to
blow say a bedroom door wide open now
check out insane scp-001 fight gate
Guardian vs Scarlet king and scp-001 the
gate Guardian